[Music]
that was a terrible crash
we're lucky to be alive
stop don't come any closer it's a girl
oh my gosh girl i'm sorry no move on
here i've just never
ever seen a girl before who
are you
it's so loud here we call it the noise
happened to all the men on this planet
every thought in our heads
we're on display
where are all the women
the dead
[Music]
why is she thinking where the hell is
her noise it's strange to see everything
you're thinking it was strange for me
too not knowing what's going on in your
head
i mean i know you might not like my dog
or you want to hit me over the head with
a rock or something
i like your dog he's stronger than he
knows
you better watch your nose snake
those men catch you they'll kill you
if you want to protect the girl you have
to leave now
with her power there's no telling what
he can do
i need that girl before she wants him
come in here tell me
200. thousands
[Music]
is this clark this uh interstellar comic
big news i don't see clark
oh maybe he's still sleeping dad
some of clark's marker fragments are now
expected to enter
our atmosphere that's right and now
those are just what are they saying
more of the same
where are they going i don't
know when first chunks is about to hit
only part of it let's go in the ocean
but you look at that
wait where's the explosion
we now are getting word that the
fragment has hit
central florida
are some more pieces gonna hit come on
let's go
put the skies on fire two days
they got it all wrong there's a ton of
fragments planet killers
space agencies are predicting an
extinction-level event
we're gonna be together all right get
him we're just trying to get to safety
they've been tracking the military
flights to bunkers and greenland
it's our only chance
[Music]
in less than 24 hours
[Music]
if you are hearing this broadcast seek
shelter immediately
what is it what's going on
there's something happening to me
there's something awakening in my mind i
can't control it
what did you see
there's a crusade coming
[Applause]
do you often dream things that happen
just as you dream them
yes
the test is simple remove your hand from
the box
and you die what's in the box
pain
[Applause]
you inherit too much power you have
proven you can rule yourself
now you must learn to rule others
something
none of your ancestors learnt
my father rules an entire planet he's
losing it
he's getting a richer one he'll lose
that one too
arrakis is a death trap
[Applause]
this is an extermination
[Applause]
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight like demons
an animal caught in a trap will nor off
its own leg
to escape what will you do
[Music]
i know you
[Music]
one day the legend will be born
all of civilization depends on it
the future i can see it
[Music]
i must not fear
fear is the mind killer
hello duke where the fear is gone
only i will remain
go go go
[Music]
oh
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway honestly
my mom won't say it but we're completely
broke
and the only thing that's left in our
name this creepy old farmhouse our
grandfather left us in the middle of
nowhere
why'd you bring me up here entertainment
value
what is that i don't know
somehow a town that isn't anywhere near
a tectonic plate
that has no fault lines no fracking no
loud music even
is shaking on a daily basis
come to the dining table now
hey remember that one summer we died on
our table
i found this in my living room killer
replica
a replica of what a ghost trap
[Music]
there hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30
years
new york in the 80s it's like the
walking dead
your dad never mentioned this to you
it's just my mom
my grandfather died my mom says we're
just here to pick through the rebel of
his life
wait a minute
[Music]
who are you
[Music]
i believe that everything happens for a
reason
come on darling
it has a gunner seat
i tell people my sister moved out west
you're a science teacher
your husband he renovates houses
you're thinking about moving but you're
gonna wait until the interest rates go
down
that's not my story
before i was an avenger i made mistakes
[Applause]
and a lot of enemies
it's called science taskmaster he
controls the red room
they're manipulated fully conscious but
no choices
i should have come back for you how many
others are there
than us
we have to go back to where it all
started so they never do that to anyone
again
we're family we fight with you
okay you got a plan or shall i just stay
dug and cover my plan was to drive us
away
gloria plan sucks
[Music]
at some point we all have to choose
between what the
[Music]
i'm done running
[Music]
here's what's going to happen natasha
don't slouch i'm not slobbering you're
going to get the back hunch
listen to your mother oh my god this up
all right enough
all of you i didn't say anything that's
not fair
sir we've landed are we still in all go
we are go
we're dropping a secret team of robots
into a country that we're not supposed
to be in it got serious the moment was
thought up
hey sign up you're all gone well i'll
kill you
do it
these people have seen everything take
them all down no witnesses
do you have an id on them yet sending
you a packet special forces huh
this guy is a deserter it could be the
ultimate field test yeah i was thinking
the same thing
she's a doctor they're all doctors
they're in a good cause
come on man okay you're scaring her
you're scaring me i'm scared
find me like a man come
you were on by humans to affect that
we're different i'm a man i have life
you're a machine
good morning goldie my name is guy and i
live
in free city i have everything i need
[Music]
except one thing hey
excuse me hey
hey bud you ever think that there's got
to be more more than what
the stuff we do day after day literally
not once
today's gonna be different goldie what
are we looking at
who are you we ran into each other the
other day how did you find me i waited
outside by the murder train guy i have
to tell you something
there is no easy way to say this this
world it's a video game
i really want to kiss you is that weird
listen to me you're not real wait you
let who kiss you guy
there's not a button for that oh he
found the button
buddy if we're not real doesn't that
mean that nothing you do matters
i am sitting here with my best friend
trying to help him get through a tough
time
now if that's not real i don't know what
it is
millie i know this world is just a game
but this place these people that's all i
have
thanks guy who is this guy this
character
in the video game free city has been
turning heads by being the good guy
who is blue shirt guy you're absolutely
right who is he
or she indeed this loser is ruining the
game man
i don't care if he's arnold freaking
schwartz invader
terminate him
we're doing great guy in two days the
game is gonna shut down
you this whole city they'll be gone what
if we can save it
[Music]
was that cool it felt really cool we can
change our world but we have to fight
together
i don't even know what's happening right
now but i love it this is the first time
i've ever driven a car before
i really wish you'd mentioned that yeah
[Music]
they seem nice
michael i've known you since you were a
child
you have a gift you always have
if there's an answer to your disease
you'll find it
i should have died years ago
why am i still here if not to fix this
i have a rare blood disease and i'm
running out of time
this can be my last chance
you're up to something what is it that's
not exactly legal
i want to see you get hurt more than you
already have
this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
[Music]
strength and
the speed to use echolocation
and an overpowering urge to consume
blood
how far are we allowed to go
go fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
michael morbius got tired of doing the
whole good guy thing huh
what's up guys
this is captain max cloud do you read
over
okay then who wants the first dance
max cloud is here
dad playing those damn games
all day every day
okay so keep it together is this real
can i touch you
pull yourself together soldier we don't
have time for this
what beer is not near cowboy is
here
[Music]
good
[Music]
literally no one was shouting
[Music]
i say the universe again you were
fantastic
[Music]
you